Sây dừng này, trong cái giờ là mới không chỉ là xây dừng này trong xe phương mạnh
mà không phải xây dừng này có mạnh đàn đồ hoàn lịch
đồ chỉ tuổi thì tính năng lịch
phương tức lấy đạo phùa, trình dành giát đất nước trong kỳ mới mới
một đạo công quen muốn dự vấn đề với cho lình đạo thì không chỉ đúng người đừng rồi
trong xe phùa tổ chức, e mới chỉ đoạn mà không phải
mạnh về tịch thì xác bạn trong dự máu
chủ đạo trong cái kinh tạo thì chế, quyết liệt trong hình đạo, rình dân xác lên
trong hình phải tây gói tình dự vấn đề với tự tình chỉ là một cái gói xong
mà còn là gì chạy về tư dưới, tụi khó với năng lịch quán chỉ
yếu cảm trong tổ chức tự vấn đề, hình chỉ muốn trong lịch đạo
qua liều xe ra ra ra mừng tìm, như ra ra xe rừng đạo phùa, gắn chạp
xe rừng người tụi chức xe rừng đưa phó quen xe rừng trụ vấn đề